machine gun kelly on fire casey neistat
acting
oh good god and whatever the hell this
is who is that
no idea
project power is netflix's latest
superhero inspired action flick that
asks the question
what if drugs could give you superpowers
we have a crackhead lifting up the box
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into project power's ending
pointing out its hidden easter eggs and
how it sets itself
up for a potential sequel so pop a pill
and make sure to like and subscribe
because here
we go project power begins where it ends
at the docks in new orleans next to a
ship called
genesis it's a bit on the nose that the
ship where a new more
powerful evolution of human will be
created is named after the first book in
the bible that recounts the creation of
humanity
genesis means the origin or beginning so
it makes sense it happens
right at the beginning of the film you
can kind of make up the name of the
company responsible for this pill here
telios which comes from the greek word
for perfection
an apt name for a company that wants to
essentially create the next evolution of
humanity
our goal is simple the next evolution of
the human species
so telios begins the process of testing
the drug out by
handing it out to local drug dealers
like newt here and these drugs are
insanely powerful allowing the user to
unlock parts of their dna
giving them superpowers for 5 minutes
the drug has
different effects for each user some can
turn into fire like newt
steel skin like frank and the ability to
grow your nails like meg
the pill can also have negative effects
like some poor bastards who just explode
that's why the drug is under
quote-unquote clinical trials we learn
from this guy here known as biggie for
reasons that will become apparent that
telios wants to harness the power and
make it
permanent imagine the power you could
wield if you had an army
of super-powered soldiers that's why he
brings a group of rich investors to
witness this power firsthand but before
we get there we're introduced to robin
reilly a high schooler pushing the power
pill to pay for her mother's surgery and
medical needs
she's actually working alongside new
orleans police officer
frank played by joseph gordon-levitt to
keep the drug off the streets
it's kind of a mutually beneficial
relationship she gets paid and he makes
sure one less pill is out of the hands
of criminals he's seen how one person on
the drug can take down an entire
precinct
and he wants to get the bottom of who's
behind it frank is the stereotypical
good
bad cop even doing impressions of clint
eastwood the actor whose many rules
portrayed that trope
he pays off dealers but for the right
reasons even giving up his bike to robin
he uses the drug too
but only to take down others who use it
on the other end of the spectrum
is art portrayed by jamie foxx like
frank he wants to bring down the
organization that is creating these
pills but
unlike frank he's not motivated by a
noble sense of making the city a safer
place
he wants one thing and one thing only
the safe return of his daughter and
he'll do anything to get that
even if it means kidnapping a high
schooler he does bad things but for good
reasons
so frank and art are quite similar
they're just motivated in different ways
art tracks down newt and i love this
subtle line as he answers the door
you alone are we all we haven't really
met art yet nor do we know about his
daughter but this line sets up his
motivation his loneliness brought upon
by the loss of his daughter
art wants to know who newt's supplier is
but newt pops a couple pills in order to
fight him off his power is turning into
flames which ironically is also what
happens when
eminem drops a diss track on him
while newt spontaneously combusts after
od on the pill we get our first glimpse
of art's daughter via flashback as we'll
learn throughout the film
art's daughter was taken from him by
telios she is the first human to have an
ability that
doesn't require the pill making her a
priceless lab rat for tellios to
experiment on
you see years ago art was a ranger for
the us military and telios being a
defense contractor
took a group of these rangers and
performed experiments on them
try to turn us into superheroes in brief
flashbacks we see that art's power was
unlocked by telios but he managed to
escape
eventually having a daughter named tracy
and it seems as though the ability to
unlock one's superpower was passed on to
his daughter kinda like fetal alcohol
syndrome yes that weird scene
where the teacher talks about how taking
drugs during pregnancy can have adverse
effects on children applies to the power
drug as well
tracy has somehow inherited power
through her father
but we'll get to that in a bit by using
newt's phone to schedule a meeting art
tracks down ramen and kidnaps her hoping
to get a lead on this mysterious bearded
man
the man who stole his daughter they make
their way to an asian supermarket and
learn that not only is telios
distributing the drug
but they're also tracking its users you
can even make out youtuber casey neistat
here another interesting thing to note
is that the office is actually located
on the back of a truck
making it a mobile unit this allows them
to go about undetected
heck even their main research facility
is located on a boat where they can move
from port to port although art and
robin's relationship gets off to a rocky
start when he kidnaps her
they soon form a bond ramen has lost a
father and art has lost his daughter
there's even a scene where he mistakes
her for his girl
this love for his daughter and children
in general is shown in a quick scene at
the gas station where he tries to make
this little girl smile
these small moments show us his humanity
a humanity rooted in the love for his
daughter
ramen ends up helping him for cash cash
covered in blood
literal blood money and as she makes the
decision whether or not to help him a
soup can rolls by her foot
she was supposed to pick up suit for her
mother reminding her of the things we do
for family
and with art telling her he's doing this
for his daughter she eventually ends up
helping him out
taking him to the vet clinic where her
mom works to stitch him up there's some
kind of irony here that as he's being
patched up there are caged animals in
the background just like he used to be
caged up by telios and how his own
daughter is
as well but there's a deeper discussion
that takes place between art and robin
that gets to the social commentary the
film is trying to explore
it's that the system is designed to keep
the people in power
in power and the people not in power
down
because in the real world the power goes
to where it always goes to the people
that already have it robin is the
perfect example of how the system makes
it difficult for her to do
anything but sell drugs her mother is a
hard-working vet tech but still can't
afford to pay for medical bills or
surgery robin can't get a job past
minimum wage so the easiest option for
her to make fast cash is selling drugs
art tells her that the way out of the
system is to find what you're good at
something we see at the end of the film
when one of her rap songs makes it on
the radio
and we see her by the pier writing
lyrics meanwhile frank is after art
after being told by the chief that art
is the one behind pushing these drugs
as we'll find out chief crane is part of
this whole conspiracy
he's working with telios to bring down
art who could jeopardize their entire
plan
i also want to mention that throughout
much of the film frank wears a new
orleans saints jersey he's the good guy
so saints is an appropriate jersey but
it's the name on the back which is more
interesting
number 37 steve gleason steve was a
safety for the saints from 2006 to 2007
where he's best known for one of the
most memorable blocks in football
history a block which led to the saints
first
point in 21 months after the superdome
was closed due to hurricane katrina
in 2011 gleason revealed he was battling
als
and became an advocate for als awareness
eventually being awarded the
congressional gold medal for his
contributions so it's kind of fitting
the heroic character in this story wears
the jersey of a heroic character
in real life frank ends up joining
forces with art after he finds out the
truth that art's daughter was captured
so that the pill could be synthesized
and tested on the new orleans populace
once it gets mass produced however the
problem will spread all across the world
if they can stabilize it then they'll
mass produce it
so whatever's happening here it's gonna
start happening everywhere
art turns himself into telios as a part
of a greater plan to save his daughter
there we meet head scientist gardner and
learn her justification for unleashing
dangerous drugs and performing
experiments on children she believes
she's a pioneer ushering in humanity to
its next
logical evolution she brings up the
example of henrietta lacks a woman whose
cancer cells were studied because
unlike normal people cells that died
when exposed to cancer
hers doubled the experiments done to her
helped scientists better understand how
viruses work
the effect of radiation on the body and
ultimately played a large role in the
development of the polio vaccine perhaps
it's a coincidence but both henrietta
and tracy are women of color
gardner believes the ends justify the
means that it's okay to do
a little bad for the greater good which
seems to be a recurring theme throughout
this film before art is saved by frank
he hints at his powers by comparing it
to that of a pistol shrimp a pistol
shrimp can fire bullets of bubbles at
its foes so strong and fast that the
sound is louder than an actual gunshot
this makes them pound for pound one of
the strongest animals on the planet
as we'll see in the film's climax art
can fire off tremendous bursts of energy
incinerating those around him he's the
pistol shrimp of new orleans but this
energy takes its toll
essentially killing him in the process
luckily his daughter has the ability to
heal this is hinted at earlier when we
see how a plant grows as she nears it as
well as biggie's presentation to the
investors where he talks about
how some animals have the ability to
heal themselves fun fact the name tracy
is derived from native irish meaning
fighter and superior
as the characters come out victorious
art says his story is done
he has his daughter and he can live his
life there's also a great shot of his
daughter taking off her medical bracelet
symbolic of her newfound freedom frank
however hints at the bigger conspiracy
that the government will likely not stop
here
they need to be exposed potentially
opening the doors for a sequel
and robin comes home and gives her
mother the much-needed money for her
surgery
oh and that can of soup which is a fun
nod to earlier in the film
robin's music is also heard on the radio
leading us to believe she's put her life
of selling drugs behind her
and has taken art's advice to follow
what she's good at but what superhero
power do you think you'd unlock if you
took the pill
me the ability to know if a movie is
good before i watch it that's all for
this video today please make sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much